ja in der Ukraine geht der Krieg weiter
und wir wollen uns heute einmal ansehen
wie wichtig nicht bloß die ganzen
modernen Waffen sind nicht nur die
ganzen Distanz Waffen sind sondern eben
auch im Kampf Mann gegen Mann wie
wichtig die Panzer sind die die Ukraine
dort einsetzen und wie Sie easy eben an
der Front nutzen diese Aufnahmen hier
sind relativ neu die wurden gestern
veröffentlicht und wir sehen hier
erstmal von einer Drohne aufgenommen ein
Panzer und nicht nur ein Panzer sondern
dieser Panzer ist tatsächlich voller
Menschen es sind hier 12 Camper drauf
die mit diesem Panzer direkt an die
Front fahren und wir sehen jetzt im
zweiten Bild gleich wie sie ihn nämlich
nutzen nämlich als Deckung und natürlich
auch als Hauptwaffe hier steigen Sie
alle ab von ihrem Panzer und nähern sich
dann der russischen Stellung die eben
direkt vor ihnen ist und wir werden
gleich sehen dass sie eben ohne diese
diesen ja diesen Panzer gar keine Chance
hätten sie zu erobern denn wir sehen
hier den Panzer wie er vorstellst und
dahinter die 12 Soldaten die jeweils die
Deckung Nutzen der Panzer in der Zeit
nutzt seine Hauptwaffe eben dieses
Panzerrohr und auch seine Waffe nämlich
die kleinen Maschinengewehre und greift
eben diese russische Stellung immer
weiter an erst kurz vor der Stellung wir
sehen das hier haben sich die Ukraine
bzw Georg ja das sind georgische
freiwillige von dem Panzer verabschiedet
gehen nach vorne er bleibt etwas weiter
hinten damit er eben nicht von dem
Panzer Abwehr Waffen der Russen hier
getroffen wird und wir sehen aber hier
die russische Stellung die von ihnen
angegriffen wird und wir sehen jetzt
auch gleich wie die Russen die dort sich
noch verbarrikadieren eben flüchten aus
dieser Stellung und diese Taktik diese
diese Kombination aus Panzer und
Infanterie ist eben etwas was wir von
den beispielsweise von den Amerikanern
da sehen wir jetzt die Russen flüchten
jetzt hier aus ihrer Stellung aus dem
von den Amerikaner aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg kennen eben diese Kombination
aus Infanterie und Panzern die zusammen
vorstoßen und nur so Ebene Chance haben
den Gegner zu überwinden das also jetzt
relativ eindrucksvoll hier von dieser
von dieser sozusagen sogenannten
Georgian legen also der georgischen
Legion innerhalb der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte genutzt aber nicht nur das
sind Aufnahmen die relativ neu sind
sondern wir haben auch russische
Aufnahmen hier ganz neu sind und das ist
von einer hellen Kamera eines Piloten
eine Helmkamera eines zu Heu 25 Piloten
das so call su25 das ist ein
erdkampfflugzeug was relativ nah am
Boden fliegt um eben den Gegner
anzugreifen wir sehen aber jetzt gleich
hier läuft alles schief nämlich
vielleicht hören wir es auch wir hören
eine Rakete die einschlägt und der Pilot
der sein eigenes Flugzeug filmt wie es
wegfliegt nachdem er sich daraus heraus
katapultiert hat hier sehen wir die
Explosion am Boden können das mal
anhalten also der Pilot der jetzt am
Fallschirm hängt und hier wir sehen sie
vorne sein eigenes Flugzeug explodieren
sieht und dann zu Boden geht und für ihn
das große Glück er hat das ganze
überlebt er hat sich also wieder
aufgerappelt nachdem er auf dieses Feld
aufgeschlagen ist und hat dann auf die
Evakuierung durch einen Hubschrauber
durch einen russischen Hubschrauber
gewartet wir sehen gleich noch mal wie
er das ganze wahrnimmt der stellt sich
also hin und sieht jetzt hier vorne auf
der linken Seite wie dort das dein
Fallschirm hier unten einmal liegt und
wie dort sein Flugzeug brennt und das
ganze wie gucken Sie mal im ersten
Moment an ist eben wirklich
beeindruckend weil man sieht wie er sich
raus katapultiert und wie dann neben ihm
sein Flugzeug zu Boden und das eben die
Szenen die hier relativ einzigartig sind
wir wollen uns noch etwas ansehen und
zwar eine Flucht eines russischen
Konvois aus Lühmann das ist bereits
einige Wochen her wir sehen uns das kurz
auf der Karte an wie man wie erinnern
uns eine Großstadt in Donalds im Norden
der Region Donalds etwa hier die von den
Ukrainern vor etwa drei Wochen befreit
wurde dort sind die Russen zu Tausenden
geflüchtet und offenbar ist ein Teil
dieser russischen Einheiten direkt in
den ukrainischen formarski reingefahren
und das sind tatsächlich unfassbare
Aufnahmen wir sehen hier ein
ukrainischen Panzer mit einem
Maschinengewehr und was wir vorne sehen
das ist ein russischer LKW ein
russischer LKW der direkt an ihm vorbei
fährt und der offenbar nicht weiß wo
sind die eigene Linien wo ist die andere
Linie jetzt haben wir gerade gesehen er
fährt direkt an ihm vorbei die Ukrainer
versuchen die aufzuhalten aber die sind
so nah dran dass man überhaupt nicht
mehr den Panzer einsetzen kann weil eben
die Entfernung nur wenige Meter sind
offen hat das Gewehr ja auch
ladeprobleme und wir sehen hier wie
gesagt die russischen Karmas LKW die mit
Artillerie dahinter versuchen
gewünschten aber eben genau an den
Ukrainern vorbei flüchten wir sehen hier
die taktischen Markierung hier ein
russischer Schützenpanzer der dazu kommt
und die Ukrainer wissen gar nicht genau
was sie machen sollen ja wie sie die
auffangen sollen wir sind aber auch
jetzt verschiedene Soldaten am
Straßenrand nämlich hier auf der rechten
Seite die auf die Panzer äh schießen und
wir sehen dass der gesamte Konvoi ja
angehalten wurde der Russen jetzt sehen
wir alle Schützenpanzer und alle
Artillerie die aufgehalten wurden so
chaotisch also der Rückzug der Russen
aus niemand der eben damit endete dass
die Russen wir sehen jetzt hier mit
ihren Fahrzeugen mit ihrer Artillerie
mit ihren Panzern direkt in die Ukraine
hineingefahren sind und dann
dementsprechend doch dann auch getötet
oder Gefangenen genommen wurden
[Musik]